my favorite fast-food fries are
hands-down McDonald's Burger King five
guys can McDonald's in turnout or like
the top two
it's good but it's not like mind blowing
yeah it's a little soggy I'm gonna
flavor reminiscent of a fried q-tips
there's no salt on it so there's no
seasoning there are certain fries that
can stand alone without ketchup these
are not those fries fluffy salty
definitely Donald's thinking about it
one is like taking a bite of my entire
childhood and the American flags it's
like a french fried that you'd make out
of play-doh plastic surgery had a little
cosmetic surgery they just taste exactly
what a fry should taste like no that's
not five guys happy fun guys so good
these are good these are like gourmet
good right it's clearly a potato it's
like this is the this is fresh from the
farm
what fries are these that's gotta be
five guys yeah that's five guys yeah
yeah yeah there's a flavor here that I'm
detecting that's unlike any other fry
flavor I've ever had dude this smells
like paint these look like reject fries
like their discount fries that's not a
french fries that's disgusting
I don't know it is I'm finishing it
that's so gross
these are interesting she's like diner
fries these taste like bowling alley
fries
hmm has a weird there's another flavor
Burger King seasoned to perfection
please I'm really into these yeah this
is winning for sure it's a very long
french fries
I've had these fries I don't know where
they're from though there's almost taste
like popcorn seasons I know yeah old
Burger Kings these taste like fries made
by a place that it doesn't normally make
fries I'm gonna go with collagen you
know this one I think they like revamp
their fries brother King yes it's got a
little bit of crunch a little bit of
sogginess to it crunchy on the outside
and on the inside just like me
Burger King French with McDonald's
that's that's like incest are you saving
these for anyone else are trying to eat
them all
I mean this is a great day like I just
came to work and now I'm eating french
fries